este inesperado verdor en el corazón de
un paisaje en el sahel es el campamento
de mina wow en camerún acoge a casi
70.000 refugiados nigerianos que huyeron
de la insurgencia de boko haram desde
2018 los refugiados han plantado decenas
de miles de árboles alrededor del
campamento pásame la regadera
semilleros de árboles que diariamente
cuidan decenas de desplazados como la
refugiada nigeriana lidia yakubu juntos
vigilan este vivero situado a las
afueras del campamento
más de 360.000 plantas han contribuido a
la reforestación de una gran parte de
esta zona árida amenazada por la
desertificación a causa del
calentamiento global
si la tiene
cuando llegamos aquí estaba
completamente vacío luego nos enseñaron
que podríamos plantar árboles para
embellecer las hordas
conseguimos algunas semillas que
plantamos y regamos todos los días
nos dijeron que las plantas atraen mucho
más agua
y los niños tendrán un lugar a la sombra
para jugar
árboles frutales plantas medicinales
árboles de sombra aquí ya se está
preparando 200.000 nuevas plantas para
reforestar esta región donde llueve tres
veces menos que en el resto del país
alrededor del campamento los refugiados
han creado 31 espacios verdes los
primeros frutos de un vasto proyecto
puesto en marcha por el alto comisionado
de las naciones unidas ante el anunciado
desastre ecológico este es un anacardo
que se acaba de plantar con motivo del
día mundial del refugiado una carrera
contrareloj el aumento de las
temperaturas acelera el proceso de la
desertificación
ruffin sólo está a cargo del programa de
reforestación del acnur y ha venido a
comprobar los progresos de la gran
muralla verde
el programa abarca ocho mil kilómetros y
11 países africanos desde dakar hasta
boutiques y se extiende desde el
atlántico hasta el océano índico
y
contribuir a reducir el avance del
desierto que crece en la zona a un ritmo
del 12 por ciento anual por ejemplo en
2021 el cambio climático afectó la
agricultura y la disponibilidad de agua
este proyecto tendrá un impacto positivo
en el clima local y la lucha contra la
desertificación también está uniendo a
las comunidades de los alrededores de
mina guau la afluencia masiva de
refugiados nigerianos había sido una
fuente de conflicto con la población
camerunesa local pero el trabajo que
realizan los refugiados ha reducido las
tensiones en la aldea para alegría del
jefe que ahora puede alimentar a todo el
ganado
en el campamento cuando los refugiados
llegaron destruyeron todos los árboles
pero como vieron cuando llegaron volvió
a ser verde y ahora está cambiando se
depende de al menos a sánchez aunque se
espera que la reforestación frene la
desertificación la batalla está lejos de
terminar ya que los refugiados y los
habitantes locales siguen necesitando
combustible para cocinar para evitar que
corten árboles para obtener leña las ong
del campamento promueven el uso de
fuentes de energía alternativas pónganse
los guantes a unas decenas de metros en
este centro de producción de briquetas
look up ha formado a más de 200 mujeres
refugiadas para transformar los residuos
domésticos en carbón ecológico los
residuos son recogidos en el campamento
clasificados secados carbonizados y
luego compactados con estas máquinas
antes de ser empacados un proyecto que
no sólo es bueno para el medio ambiente
sino que también crea un ambiente de paz
entre las diferentes comunidades la
implementación del proyecto del carbón
ecológico nos ha permitido reducir la
tala de madera de forma bastante
significativa pero además como
utilizamos los residuos de los cultivos
nos permite limpiar el campamento y
proteger el medio ambiente este carbón
vegetal se utiliza tanto en el
campamento como en los pueblos de
acogida la producción de carbón
ecológico también se ha convertido en
una fuente ingresos para refugiados como
had ya una madre de cinco hijos que vive
en mina guau desde 2016 es la presidenta
de una cooperativa de unas 100 mujeres
la reforestación ha cambiado sus vidas
las ha hecho independientes y
económicamente autosuficientes aunque el
hecho breve sellering discurso madrazo
nin quiso el dinero que ganó con la
venta de briquetas de carbón me permite
comprar jabón a mis condimentos y carne
para mi familia
puedes elegir ahora más que nunca a
estas familias en mina guau se enfrentan
a la falta de recursos esenciales y
sienten el impacto del cambio climático
el calentamiento global amenaza sus
vidas a diario con el tiempo se
plantarán más de medio millón de árboles
alrededor del campamento con la
esperanza de que los protejan del
aumento de las temperaturas
[Música]